today would have been marco gonzalez's
start he's on the injured list so today
is another bullpen day for the mariners
right-hander robert duggar is going to
open on the boundary that'll bring up
third baseman jose ramirez who was three
for three last night with three doubles
robert shakes off one sign and likes the
next
now the wind-up and again the one-two
pitch breaking ball swing and a miss for
strike three duggar strikes out jose
ramirez and that's it for the tribe and
the top of the first nice start for
robert duggar we go to the bottom of the
first indians nothing and the mariners
coming up bieber enters today riding an
all-time major league record he has gone
20 straight starts entering this
afternoon with at least eight strikeouts
he faces kyle seeger oh and to the count
on seeger runner at second here's the
pitch breaking ball swung on and missed
strike three the ball was dropped by
hedges he picks it up throws on to first
to complete the strikeout
and that'll bring up centerfielder kyle
lewis
the two-nothing pitch of kyle swinging a
line shot base hit into center field
here comes hannah ronny thor being waved
in by maniacta up with the ball is
luplow and he tosses the ball softly
into second base kyle lewis with a two
out rbi single
and the mariners have an early lead one
to nothing here in the bottom of the
first inning on a clutch base hit by
lewis
crawford hitting 250 with a home run a
dozen driven in
the 2-2 slider swung on and missed
strike three
crawford down on strikes side retired
but seattle scores the game's first run
and we'll head to the second it's one
nothing bearing
big man six
five 265 pounder anfield is way back in
the left side donovan walton getting the
start at third base today for the
mariners kyle siegert the dh next pitch
swing anime strike three robert duggar
striking out reyes and there's one away
for the tribe here in the top half of
the second there's one away for the
indians that'll bring up right fielder
josh naylor
3-2 pitch and it's strike three called
and naylor knew it
so another strikeout for robert duggar
that's three in a row
top of any number two the banner will be
first baseman jake bowers
shift on and dylan moore the second
baseman way out there in right field
here is the stretch now the one-two on
the way in a swing and a miss and a
change-up for strike three and robert
duggar strikes out the side here in the
top half of the second four strikeouts
already
torrens on the season hitting 190 a pair
of home runs
six runs driven in
the 2-2
breaking ball called strike three on the
inside corner
bieber chalks up his third strikeout
side retired in order we head to the
third the number nine hitter donovan
walton will lead things off for seattle
miss chase one of the dirt
four strikeouts for shane bieber first
time through the order
the mariners have the bases loaded for
j.p crawford
up the middle into center field
hannigar's clapping his hands coming
home here comes seeger
not in time seeger is safe
jp crawford drives in a pair
three nothing mariners
more the sixth man make that the seventh
man to the plate here in the third
inning bieber trying to get out of it
finally does
three nothing mariners runner second two
down and here's josh naylor reyes elite
at second here's the pitch on the way
and it's strike three called he got him
looking with a fastball at 95 miles an
hour a couple of strikeouts
for paul seawall in his mariners debut
this afternoon we go to the bottom of
the fourth hour score
it's the mariners three and the indians
nothing
one down for luis torrance who is oh for
his last 11. here's the 2-2
swing and a missed strength three
got him with a slider
and that is strikeout number six for
fever
the indians will bring the tight run to
the plate and hernandez with bowers at
second and jimenez on at first base
runners their leads bowers and ximena is
the stretch of the 2-2 and a swing and a
miss for strike three
seawall strikes out cesar hernandez and
the indians
leave two runners stranded that is
strikeout number four already for paul
seawall in just two innings of relief
here's kyle seeger with the runner at
second and one out
and the o2
swinging a mess he struck him out that
gives him seven
and there are two down in the fifth
now the mariners have runners on it
first and second with two outs and
that'll bring up jp crawford
fourth walk
wow how about that
his streak
his historic streak
20 straight starts with the least eight
strikeouts it ends today in seattle
seven strikeouts for bieber who exits
when the base is loaded
this is the first time that bieber did
not go at least five innings
since june of
2019 it's 40 straight starts he had done
that
crunch time here for phil maton in a
three nothing ball game the mariners
already in front
they have the bases loaded
with two outs as meiton comes on in
relief of shane bieber here in the fifth
he is facing dylan moore a red hot
hitter
here it comes
swinging and i missed strike three matan
comes through
and works out of the jam no damage done
josh naylor steps in he's been up twice
struck out twice
blasted one to right on friday night
here's the pitch to him swing and a line
drive on one hop to the second baseman
moore who scoops it up and throws to
first in time for the out rosario scores
from third
naylor's retired and the indians are on
the scoreboard it's now seattle three
and the tribe won
jordan luplow will be the batter
ramirez is at third
two outs in the inning the 3-2 pitch
swung on ground ball to the third
baseman knocked down by walton but he
can't pick it up
the ball rolls free safe at first is
luplow and that allows ramirez to score
from third
and the indians push home another run
it's now a one-run ball game seattle
three and the tribe two
the hitter's gonna be the catcher austin
hedges the 0-2 swaying in a missed
struck he met him three pitches
two runs
on two hits an error two left
we go bottom six so you take a chance
with the big guy here friend bill reyes
who struck out doubled to right and
struck out
ready
and he comes set the pitch
broken back ground ball to walton throws
over to second for one overs double play
inning over
that was beautifully timed nothing
across for the tribe
here's jp crawford you can ill afford
to let them fall away now right
add on to what they're doing right oh
outside corner
crawford doesn't like it
inning over here's kelnick
oh for four
here's the one two
swung on tap up the first base side
fairball picked up by bowers who takes
it to the bag in time for the out so
class a works around a pair of walks and
we'll head to the night
one on with two outs
and the batter will be the left fielder
eddie rosario here's the set
by kendall and the 2-1 pitch swung on
ground ball right side chopper charging
dylan moore he's got it the throw to
first and the ball game is over the
merit has won it three to two this
afternoon over the indians and they win
the series three games to one the
mariners jump back over the 500 mark